[Musica]
tornare sui miei passi
mi capita
tutti i giorni
più volte al giorno un po per carattere
e un po perché fa parte del mio mestiere
e a voi
è mai capitato di tornare sui vostri
passi
c'è e vi è mai successo di pensare che
sia bello
a me sì
nella danza è un continuo tornare
indietro
incredibile passano gli anni più bello e
più
ho l'impressione di tornare alle base al
punto di inizio
anche se non saprei dire con esattezza
quale sia stato il mio punto d'inizio
sera danza sia stata una causa
oppure un effetto quello che so è che da
un certo punto in poi per me è stato
necessario proseguire danzando avevo 15
anni
molti pensano che si debba iniziare da
piccoli
che si debba
forgiare il corpo quando la materia
ancora duttile e vero quello che è
strano però è che quando mi capita di
vedere dei bambini di due o tre anni
muoversi con una armonia che toglie il
fiato beh mi verrebbe da pensare il
contrario e cioè che tutto quello che
serve per danzare in realtà ce l'abbiamo
già dalla nascita
nello stesso kit di base che ci fa
espandere il petto se abbiamo bisogno di
accumulare più aria o che ci fa vibrare
quando non siamo più nella pelle o che
ci fa rimbalzare quando abbiamo il
fiatone
insomma
tornare al punto di inizio
molti pensano da piccoli materia ancora
adulti le stanno però beh kit di base e
spandere vibrare
rimbalzare 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 è più
forte di me mi capita tutti i giorni e
tornando sui miei passi
forse la prima vera sfida è stata
abituare il cuore prima a tornare a casa
poi a starci a casa a stare lì dov'è nel
mio corpo
perché il nostro corpo non è forse la
nostra casa per tutta la vita
e la danza
la danza penso sia un continuo tentativo
di rendere ospitale questo corpo ma è
una gran faticaccia sapete ogni
danzatore sa che ogni mattina il suo
corpo è come una casa fredda disordinata
eppure da lì che deve partire da quella
da quella resistenza da quel torpore di
ossa e muscoli che certi giorni proprio
non ne vogliono sapere di rispondere
presente all'appello soprattutto quei
giorni in cui anche solo
respirare fa male
ma questo non penso non sia solo un
problema di noi danzatori o sbaglio
forse la differenza sta nel fatto che
noi
prima di danzare ci scaldiamo
test scapole gomiti mani
torace colonna bacino ginocchia piedi
ancora testa scapole gomiti mani torace
colonna bacino ginocchia pd ripeto testa
scapole gomiti mani storace colonna
bacino ginocchia a piedi o ragazzi ci
siete tutti e c'è qualcuno che entra la
seconda ora questo facciamo
facciamo appello
facciamo spazio
scaldiamo casa
infatti
adesso sento che in un in un punto
riparato del mio corpo
il mio cuore ha cambiato ritmo
bentornato a casa gli dico
ai memorizzato la strada
rivediamo
tornare al punto di inizio molti pensano
da piccoli materia ancora duttile strano
però ben kit di base e spandere vibrare
rimbalzare abituare il cuore ma una gran
faticaccia sapete quella resistenza a
testa scapole gomiti mani torace colonna
bacino ginocchia piedi presente
e
adesso che sono caldo
riuscirò a danzare da qui
riuscirò ad essere gentili da qui
i danzatori
si scaldano per non farsi male
esiste un riscaldamento per non farsi
male con le parole
mi rendo conto
che la danza e l'esperienza di un
movimento non finalizzato
praticamente non serve a niente non
serve a schivare un ostacolo a svitare
una lampadina ad allacciarmi un paio di
scarpe e solo danza esattamente come un
gesto gentile
agito senza voler ottenere nulla
qualcosa che non va ha spiegato nessuna
giustificazione
solo danza
se quella giusta non servono le
didascalie allora mi viene in mente
ci andrai via candiani ha scritto la
gentilezza e danza non è mimmo
altrimenti sarebbe cortesia
allora penso che a furia di scaldare il
corpo un giorno finirà che ammorbidì rho
anche il cuore lo renderò disponibile a
trattare per una pace tra il mio fuori e
il mio dentro
per questo adesso ho bisogno di
rallentare
e
di chiudere per un istante gli occhi
fai quello che poi mi dico la
simultaneità tra danza e parola mi rende
un po instabile e mi sta chiedendo punti
di riferimento non solo visivi spaziali
ma anche interiori
bussa alla porta la paura di perdere il
filo del discorso e fare una pessima
figura davanti a voi
benvenuta gli dico si accomodi a ma c'è
anche il dubbio il dubbio di non essere
all'altezza lo stavo aspettando
benvenuto bentrovato anzi faccio anche
la sfiducia cosa ci siamo dati un
appuntamento stasera
vai
quello che puoi mi dico
ci vuole allenamento
bisogna farsi il fiato
così si dice solo che a me tutto questo
tornare indietro sui miei passi
mi mette una gran voglia
di mandare tutti a quel paese
altro che gentilezza
mi viene voglia di mandare tutti a quel
paese altro che gentilezza
eppure a pensarci bene è come se si è
come se di là tassi lo spazio è come se
moltiplicasse la possibilità di essere
gentile e in che modo
curiosando oltre la mia cine sfera
la cina sfera un termine tecnico
coreografico
indica lo spazio che ci circonda
e che si estende tanto quanto possiamo
allungare gli arti nelle varie direzioni
questa per esempio la mia genere fera io
la mia la immagino con un grande
gomitolo invisibile che contiene tool
team i movimenti i miei movimenti
poi vi vedo
mi accorgo che a pochi metri di distanza
c'è una platea di esseri umani
ognuno con la sua
inconsapevole cine sfera
quando due persone si avvicinano due
cine sfere entrano in contatto
quando io mi avvicino a voi le nostre
cine sfere
entrano in contatto
solo che spesso
siamo così occupati ad arredare i nostri
metri cubi di mondo che neanche ci
accorgiamo di essere entrati nella
stessa rotta di collisione di un altro
essere siamo degli asfaltatori seriali
senza volerlo lasciamo dietro di noi una
scia di morti e feriti ovunque per un
gesto frettoloso per una parola fuori
luogo
e fuori cine sfera
ho fatto un casino
e adesso
come riparo
sì perché oltre che un atto creativo
tornare sui miei passi può rivelarsi
anche un
modo per prendermi cura
non a caso si dice gesto riparatore
non parola non pensiero gesto riparatore
e la danza mi aiuta a dilatare lo spazio
così che da semplice luogo di
deambulazione personale diventa spazio
di incontri di gesti condivisi e quindi
potenzialmente sconfinato e scusate ma
non è la stessa cosa anche per la
gentilezza
in fondo e accorgersi che tra noi e il
resto del mondo non esiste una reale
linea di demarcazione
e questo non ci fa percepire il mondo
più grande
e poi la diffidenza il calcolo il dubbio
la prepotenza non sono forse l'esatto
opposto c'è un restringimento dello
spazio una contrattura del mondo beh
allora
io
io voglio
io voglio danzare
io voglio danzare e non
io voglio danzare in un mondo io voglio
danzare in un mondo più grande io voglio
danzare in un mondo più grande della mia
io voglio danzare in un mondo più grande
della mia cine sfera
e tornando sui miei passi mi accorgo di
non essere solo
per questo ho bisogno di prendermi cura
dei miei movimenti
selezionare quelli giusti
combinarli nel miglior modo possibile
variarli
pensando all'equilibrio
non come una regola fissa perfetta ma ad
un laboratorio creativo ad una pratica
ad un espediente
per non scappare da tutte le cose e le
persone che incontriamo tutti i giorni
un equilibrio tra tutti i paesi che
disperdono e tutti i paesi che
trattengono a volte con amore a volte
con cieca ostinazione
un equilibrio tra forza e leggerezza tra
movimento legato e movimento staccato un
equilibrio tra le distanze
perché
certe parole come certe persone
rischiano di andare a sbattere
un tempo giusto
perché certe risposte come certi gesti
richiedono il controllo di un adagio
al contrario gli abbracci i baci e
grazie non ammettono esitazione ma
ripetizione un ritornello un bahlsen chi
devono rimanere in testa per giorni per
ore se vuoi che diventino danza
ea furia di tornare sui miei passi
questo cerchio
finirà inevitabilmente di allargarsi
cosicché da un solo corpo che danza
diverrà tanti corpi che danzano
senza scopo
nessuna giustificazione solo
danza
provateci
quando siete soli a casa spostati mobili
mettete una musica che vi piace
fregatevene non giudicate vi
permettete alla danza di tornare di
stupirvi così come fa la gentilezza
quindi
torno sui miei passi così come posso
scavando nel cuore
a random
dissodando
seminando
innaffiando poi aspetto
il tempo del germogliare
non dovremmo fare la stessa cosa con le
parole
selezionarle meglio
combinarle meglio
variarle dando più peso alle loro
differenze così da maneggiare meglio la
complessità del mondo e perché no
pensarle prima di pronunciarle per non
ferire più nessuno per non dover dire
poi troppi scusa mi dispiace
per non dover fare troppi troppi passi
indietro
cosa ne dite
ci proviamo
grazie
[Applauso]